[Música]
la corte constitucional de Ecuador
rechaza las demandas de
inconstitucionalidad contra el decreto
de muerte Cruzada emitido por el
presidente Guillermo lasso con el que
evitó un juicio político por lo tanto se
mantiene en firme la convocatoria de
nuevas elecciones
en Colombia avanza la búsqueda de los
cuatro menores indígenas desaparecidos
tras un accidente de avioneta en el
Amazonas el 1 de Mayo después de un
cruce de información contradictoria las
autoridades aseguran que no
establecieron contacto con los niños
en Estados Unidos nuevo episodio en la
batalla entre la compañía Walt Disney y
el gobierno republicano del estado de
Florida Disney canceló la creación de un
campus valorado en mil millones de
dólares que habría creado 2000 empleos
en el estado
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más relevantes
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos en Ecuador porque la corte
constitucional rechazó 6 demandas
presentadas por la oposición contra la
medida de muerte Cruzada decretada por
el presidente Guillermo lasso un
mecanismo con el que el mandatario
disolvió el parlamento y evitó un juicio
político en su contra por supuesta
malversación por lo tanto se mantiene el
adelanto de elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas desde quito Gustavo Ortega
tiene los detalles
seis demandas Fueron inadmitidas por
parte de la corte constitucional
presentadas contra el decreto
presidencial de la muerte Cruzada con el
dictamen de inadmisibilidad emitido por
la corte constitucional la decisión del
presidente es irrevocable seis jueces y
juezas del organismo analizaron las
demandas que contemplaban la disolución
de la asamblea nacional y la
convocatoria a elecciones generales
anticipadas la oposición ha sostenido
que el decreto es ilegal por no existir
conmoción política y social en Ecuador
los pedidos presentados ante la Corte
buscaban revertir la decisión y los
efectos establecidos en la Constitución
ecuatoriana pero el máximo intérprete de
la Constitución nacional detalló en su
dictamen que en la corte constitucional
ni otra autoridad judicial del país
tiene competencia para pronunciarse
respecto a la verificación y motivación
de grave crisis política y comoción
interna invocada por el presidente para
disolver la asamblea nacional con el
dictamen de la corte el presidente de la
república Guillermo lasso celebró la
decisión del organismo
que la decisión Está pegada a derecho
los ahora ex asambleístas deberán
respetar la medida y prepararse para
unas elecciones para concluir el actual
periodo en Ecuador ya empiezan a sonar
los nombres de quienes podrían ser los
posibles aspirantes a la primera
magistratura inclusive el actual
presidente podría volver a postularse
para concluir su periodo sin que eso sea
tomado como una reelección Mientras que
el organismo electoral debe aprobar en
el pleno si Se confirma no el 20 de
agosto para convocar a los Ecuatorianos
nuevamente a las urnas
y en Colombia dos semanas después del
trágico accidente de una avioneta de
pasajeros en la espesa selva amazónica
un mensaje de Esperanza generó confusión
e indignación en el país y es que el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro se
tuvo que retractar después de anunciar
el hallazgo con vida de cuatro menores
desaparecidos tras el siniestro las
fuerzas militares encargadas de la
búsqueda al parecer no han hecho
contacto directo con ellos Marina
sardinha tiene la historia
le pido un favor que yo soy su abuelita
Fátima usted me entiende tiene que estar
quieta porque ellos le están buscando 18
días en vilo y un país aún a la espera
de un milagro las fuerzas militares de
Colombia continúan la búsqueda de cuatro
niños indígenas huitoto desaparecidos
desde el 1 de Mayo la pequeña avioneta
de pasajeros en la que viajaban se
estrelló en plena selva amazónica en el
sur del país ante la confusión mediática
en la que se anunció que los menores
habían sido encontrados con vida los
familiares exigieron respeto la salud
física y emocional no es un juego que
pueda ser borrado o fácilmente olvidado
la persecución de los medios de
comunicación para dar declaraciones no
solo desconoce nuestros derechos sino
que violenta y Aviva el dolor víctima de
dicha confusión fue el propio presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro quien tuvo que
rectificar su mensaje inicial admitiendo
que el hallazgo de los niños de 13 9 4
años y un bebé de 11 meses aún no ha
sido confirma He decidido Borrar el
tweet porque no ha sido posible
confirmar la información facilitada por
el icbf Lamento lo sucedido las fuerzas
militares y las comunidades indígenas
continuarán su inquieta búsqueda para
que podamos entregarle al país la
noticia que está esperando en este
momento no hay otra prioridad que seguir
adelante hasta encontrarlos la vida de
los niños es lo más importante fueron
los mismos miembros de la comunidad
indígena quienes dieron con el paradero
de la avioneta siniestrada la comunidad
aprovechó la coyuntura mediática para
denunciar las precarias condiciones de
seguridad de las pistas de aterrizaje en
esas áreas remotas de la amazonía la
operación a Esperanza como bautizaron a
la misión de rescate si en curso
y vamos a Estados Unidos porque allí
continúa la batalla entre el gobernador
de Florida el republicano ron de santis
y la compañía Walt Disney este jueves
sus directivos anunciaron la cancelación
de un campus que suponía una inversión
de mil millones de dólares y la creación
de 2.000 empleos desde Miami Anthony
beltchinos amplía
Disney ha cancelado un plan de mil
millones de dólares aquí en Florida en
medio de la disputa del gigante del
entretenimiento con el gobernador del
estado el republicano de Santi es la
compañía a través de un comunicado ha
aludido a los considerables cambios
desde el anuncio del proyecto lo que ha
hecho que los responsables de Disney
pues tomaran la decisión de suspender
este plan todo eso ocurre días después
de que el Gobernador de santis firmara
una ley para que fuera el estado quien
inspeccionará el mono raílele de los
parques Disney desde hace 52 años el
sistema era supervisado por el distrito
autónomo de los parques de hecho la
compañía gozaba de una especie de
autonomía para poder regular la
distribución del agua o las carreteras
del terreno donde están construidos esos
parques pero ya de santis amenazó el año
pasado con eliminar esa autonomía
después de que Disney se opusiera
públicamente a la ley no digas gay
aprobada por el gobernador y que prohíbe
que en las escuelas hasta los 18 años
que hable de la orientación sexual o la
identidad de género finalmente de
Sánchez cumplió con su amenaza y se hizo
cargo del distrito de Disney una
decisión que ni siquiera entienden desde
el partido republicano aquí en Florida
ya que muchos han salido a criticar al
gobernador por esta medida dicen que eso
va en contra del capitalismo y la
libertad de cada uno en Estados Unidos
pero lo cierto es que esta noticia
también llega en un momento en el que
cada vez suena con más fuerza la
posibilidad de que ron de Santi es
presente su candidatura presidencial por
el partido republicano la semana próxima
podría hacer el anuncio de momento él no
lo confirmaba
vamos ahora a Argentina donde miles de
ciudadanos protestaron en Buenos Aires
contra el gobierno por la situación
económica que vive el país la inflación
interanual es superior al 108% y los
niveles de pobreza se acerca en el 40%.
los manifestantes que pertenecen a
distintos movimientos sociales denuncian
que perciben bajos ingresos tienen
empleos precarios o se sostienen con
ayuda estatal
en otras noticias las autoridades de
México informaron que fueron rescatadas
49 personas migrantes entre ellas 11
menores que habían sido secuestradas el
lunes cuando viajaban en un autobús en
el norte del país las personas se
desplazaban desde la ciudad de Tapachula
hacia la frontera con Estados Unidos y
según informaciones preliminares El
secuestro fue autoría de un grupo armado
ilegal que luego extorsionó a las
víctimas para liberarlas los migrantes
provenían de Venezuela Honduras Brasil
Haití y El Salvador
los primeros migrantes nos dieron la
información que habían llegado una
gasolinera cargar combustible y de ahí
habían sido abordados por
miembros de la delincuencia organizada
ese era el único dato que que se había
obtenido inicialmente no pero nos
ayudará mucho lo que estén haciendo
ahorita las autoridades con ellos para
enfocar las operaciones que tenemos allá
y cerramos en El Salvador que desplegó
5000 soldados y 500 oficiales de policía
para rodear la localidad de Nueva
concepción al noroeste del país con la
medida que llega tras una nueva prórroga
del estado de excepción se busca
arrestar a los responsables del
asesinato de un oficial de policía
presuntamente a manos de pandilleros
ayer el presidente nayib bukele
arremetió contra las ong defensoras de
derechos humanos y prometió arrasar con
los que calificó de mal asesinos si es
necesario hay que asumir lo que nos toca
verdad cada quien a veces este no queda
no siempre nos da problema el saber
verdad se siente una presión bastante
fuerte en ver tanta seguridad pero es
necesario la verdad digamos así al final
de esta edición pero sigan con más
información en 24 y 24 punto com
[Música]